follow your passion I get a lot of
people right in intimacy Evan do you
think this is a good business idea or
not and and for me you can make money in
any business in any industry you can
make money if you are following your
passion if you're helping people you are
adding value to people's lives you can
make money one of the foundational rules
here of business is if you add a lot of
value to people's lives you will make a
lot of money you want to make money
add lives that add value to people's
lives you want to make money quickly add
value quickly the people's lives
and you can do that in any industry the
key is that you're passionate about it
so whatever field you're trying to get
into if you're doing it just for the
money you're not gonna be successful but
if you're doing it because you love it
because you're helping people because
you're changing people's live and them
using your product or service their eyes
light up they go home talking about you
because of how you've helped them do
something like that's that's important
stuff that's where you can build a
business around it doesn't matter what
industry you're in
and so my opinion on us on the industry
Irv's type of business it doesn't really
matter because I could tell you yes
that's a great industry look at the
growth rates it's taking off you should
definitely get into it but if you're not
passionate about it you're gonna fail
meanwhile there's a industry that's
declining every year is going down and
down and down but you're coming in with
a new passion and the way of doing
something you can make tons of money
there so it doesn't matter the industry
doesn't matter what you're getting into
it's more are you doing something that
you're passionate about so this comes as
a result of one of my youtube work fans
writing in love you guys
Exxon who wrote a long message thanking
for the videos basically wrote in to say
he wants to start a business with with
this friend in real estate something as
an online service his friends an expert
MIT and he writes in to say what's your
opinion on starting an online service
for example in real estate so we can
look into the business to gain
experience and also start something at
the same time I appreciate your work in
your response Exxon
again like real-estate great online
great can you make money absolutely is
this something that you're passionate
about I don't know that's gonna be the
key thing right do you and your partner
both love this do you have a vision of
how you're gonna change the world and
make it a better place because of this
online tool that you're creating if you
do then go for you can make tons of
money you can be hugely successful but
if you don't if it's something just
whatever you know put a little time into
it see if it works that's not a business
it's not gonna work like stop now and do
something that you're passionate about
so what you've got to figure out is is
this just a hobby right is this
something that you're gonna test out
you're gonna put a little time into it
you're gonna work on your skills do you
want to learn the industry a little bit
so you're gonna do it by learning then
whatever go for it try it out you'll
learn but your part learn more going and
being mentored by somebody right if you
want to learn about the real estate
industry the best way to do it is to go
be mentored by somebody in the real
estate industry who's built exactly what
you want to do because you're learning
from all of their years of experience
and they're showing you the ropes so you
don't have to try to figure it all out
yourself but if you're doing it because
you know you have a passion for this you
really want to build something special
and your partner feels the same way then
it's a great idea launch it up let me
know where that comes out I want to
check it out - I'm not that huge in real
estate but I also check out the site
it's important message for anybody
watching the video a lot of people want
to become entrepreneurs right there's
such an allure right like I want to be
my own boss when I set my own hours I
don't want to work for some idiot who
doesn't understand me I'm tired of
working for a company that you know
doesn't care about their employees or
doesn't stand for anything important
okay there's a lot of there's a lot of
reasons to want to start a business but
the one that should pull you in is you
have a vision for the world that is
different right you want to change the
way something is done and that is
motivating you to start this company you
don't want to
run away from a life that you don't like
right your job your co-workers your boss
the company you don't want to just run
away from a life that you don't like you
want to be running towards something
that you love and I don't want you to
waste your time and money and effort and
energy and and lose confidence and and
do all that trying the company just
because you're trying to make money and
avoid this life that you hate I want you
to run to something that you love
something that's gonna really impact
people something that is gonna help
change the world something you feel
proud of to say I made that I'm part of
this this is awesome
and when you do that that's the right
business to be a part of believe for
those of you watching let me know you
think let me know how you found your
passion leave it in the comments section
below if you like this video you can
support me by clicking the link in the
description and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon